especially after what happened with
Russia last year where a number of
countries froze uh their their Central
Bank Reserves it got me thinking about
if you've got a central bank they're
kind of worried about this type of risk
then potentially they might want to
acquire a decent amount of
cryptocurrency do you think that there
are any countries who likely have
already done this and just not revealed
it
all right guys bang bang I've got
Matthew here with me uh Matthew you
recently published in November a uh
paper that is titled hedging sanctions
risk cryptocurrency and Central Bank
Reserves and this paper got whipped
around the internet obviously by a lot
of bitcoiners but also I saw quite a bit
of conversation coming from traditional
finance and even people who would fancy
themselves kind of Central Bank experts
maybe we could just start with uh why
someone from the Department's uh the
department of Economics at Harvard would
even be interested in the intersection
of central banks and something like
Bitcoin where did that interest come
from and kind of what put you down this
path
yeah so
um personally thank you for having me on
your podcast it's always fun to have an
opportunity to talk talk about my
research especially with an audience
that think it's yours
um but I think actually I I got into
this topic not through the crypto angle
but rather through the sanctions angle
so I was thinking about I was long but
interested in in the effects of
sanctions on the International Financial
system
and uh especially after what what
happened with Russia last year where a
number of countries froze uh their their
Central Bank Reserves it got me thinking
about you know one of the one of the
effects of this might be that central
banks might think about uh reallocating
their reserves or in anticipation of of
uh of this type of risk sort of trying
to protect themselves from it and um and
so you know kind of logically falling
from that so the question you want to
ask yourself is well what could they buy
that would protect themselves from this
type of risk
um obviously gold uh at least if you
have physical custody of it uh would
would be one potential answer and but
but I think uh Bitcoin might be might be
another and so that that was where the
paper came from sort of exploring
whether
um Bitcoin cert can serve as either a
substitute or a complement for gold uh
in in that sense
um yeah
so what's fascinating with the latest
round of U.S sanctions uh in the Russia
Ukraine conflict is the United States
has been using Financial sanctions for a
long time now uh against a number of
different countries but I think that
there was a fairly widespread belief
that these sanctions both the speed and
the severity of them kind of signaled a
new regime or a new paradigm of
financial sanctions there was the
freezing of Central Bank assets there
was a kind of a global coordinated
effort talk a little bit about the
actual use of sanctions and kind of how
you evaluate you know maybe their
historical use but then also what's your
take on uh these sanctions against
Russia and and how severe they were and
kind of the global coordination that was
used to actually Implement them
yeah so I mean I so my paper doesn't uh
estimate like the the uh the impact of
sanctions on the Russian economy per se
but it certainly seems that that they've
had some effects uh We've the Western
world as sanctioned Russia's Imports
more than its exports so uh that really
causes them some major supply chain
issues when when it comes to trying to
manufacture and build stuff
um
I I think what makes this this an
interesting topic is that when it comes
to these these sanctions there's not
just one thing that can get you
sanctioned so obviously in the case of
Russia the the sanctions were applied
because they invaded a neighboring
country uh but there are other central
banks that have also had their reserves
Frozen by the U.S for a variety of other
reasons ranging from building nuclear
weapons to uh terrorism-related concerns
to just having a government that the U.S
doesn't recognize like uh Venezuela for
example
um so well and Alpha which you know
maybe the human rights ability concerns
thrown in there too but but
um there's just kind of this grab bag of
of things uh and that's what makes it
interesting is that uh uh there's not
just one thing and and you know and the
other thing too is the sanctions are up
to the U.S president and um Congress can
overrule uh the the imposition of
sanctions but that would take a
two-thirds majority to do that so uh
really if you're thinking about
um
you know the central bank would be
thinking about holding uh Assets in the
United States you've got to ask yourself
how much you trust the U.S president
when you see the sanctions I think for
me someone who does not spend a lot of
time studying sanctions even studying
maybe Central Bank uh kind of chess
moves if you will in the geopolitical
stage uh the thing that surprised me was
the freezing of assets that were not in
the actual sovereignty of the nation
right so these are uh dollars or other
foreign currencies that are being stored
outside of Russia uh they were gold
reserves being stored outside of Russia
I believe that there was another
situation where Venezuela's gold was
sort of like the bank of England if I
remember correctly yeah and there was uh
the
um kind of uh rejection of Venezuela's
requests to return their gold to them
and so it became very obvious to me like
you would think the central bank would
have the National Assets at the central
bank but then it kind of highlighted
like no that's not how this works and so
how common is it for there to be
sanctions on these assets that are not
held within the country
yeah so well first of all let's get to
how common is it that the country's
store assets outside of their own
borders uh it's it's relatively common
um and it really gets actually this sort
of tension between uh like what are the
benefits of having a centralized
Financial system versus a decentralized
one well in a centralized system uh you
have lower transaction costs because you
have these Central clearinghouses that
can facilitate transactions uh you know
a good example that being the New York
Fed so they in the in the Vault of the
New York fed uh are quite a bit of gold
uh that belongs to about 36 different uh
International organizations and central
banks and it's nice the benefit to them
is that there's low transaction costs
well first of all because the New York
State kind of handles the custody and
the security of it and all that but also
if they if one of those countries wants
to transact with another uh country
that's also got their gold at the New
York fed
um some staff from the New York fed will
literally just take the gold bars off of
one shelf in the vault and move them to
the other shelf and uh and so it's just
very easy to to conduct transactions on
the other hand yeah you then you know
once you once you store your office
outside of your own borders yeah I mean
you you do have to ask yourself the
question of are they going to be
returned if I want them and um yeah
you're right that that Venezuela has had
a dispute with with the bank of England
which as far as I'm aware they're pretty
much lost so so the the British courts
have not um uh given Venezuela any
relief in terms of repatriating it's
It's Gold
um
so yeah I mean I think that that in in
general
um
uh you know there's also just the fact
that the the traditional sort of Western
Financial system is well regulated and
stable and so that also makes it an
attractive place to store and and
custody assets uh so yeah I mean I think
it's because I think it's quite common
that that uh
you know people would store uh in
institutions would have accounts uh
outside of their home borders
when I think about Venezuela asking the
bank of England for their gold back
um one I'm imagining that the British
courts uh have an issue with uh
Venezuelan government human rights all
the things that you know probably the
U.S also uh would take object to
um but also there's this element of if
we tell them to kick rocks and we say
you're not getting your gold back they
can't really do anything
and if you kind of compare that to you
know maybe the United States if a
country somewhere in the world said to
the United States you're not getting
your gold back uh we got a pretty
powerful Swift and effective military
and it feels like we actually could do
something now whether we did or not
would be up for debate and the details
of that situation and so is there this
element also of not just uh which
country it is and human rights and stuff
but also just like if you don't have a
really strong military then like you
kind of uh are at a disadvantage and
countries know that
yeah uh so so that's that's that's an
interesting uh point and I I do believe
that that in some of the military uh
conflicts like in in Europe for example
in the 19th century that uh like one of
the motivations for conquering uh
another country was was to acquire its
gold reserves for yourself uh and so
yeah I mean I mean I think historically
maybe that that's been a motivation or
one motivation anyway for for conflict
um
you know in in your example is sort of
it's actually asymmetric because I I
don't think the U.S stores any of its
sold outside of its own border so you
would never have a situation where a
country would be refusing to give uh the
u.s's gold back to itself
um but yeah I know that I mean you are
you are right that uh in terms of you
know Venezuela if the British courts
don't
give release to Venezuela that there's
not a whole lot they can they can do
[Music]
yeah it's uh it's crazy to think about
and so if we then take like the
Venezuela example and maybe we just
extend that out to the Russian uh
situation uh it seems very similar like
Russia had a bunch of foreign currencies
uh gold uh other assets that were on
their central bank balance sheet they
had them stored elsewhere and it seems
like this although likely was led by the
U.S uh it was NATO it was kind of This
Global coordination and many countries
decided all at once that they were going
to freeze assets and kind of cut Russia
off from this Global Financial system
once that occurs is it the belief that
like we've breached kind of this new
paradigm and therefore this will become
the Playbook I kind of think of it like
uh the 2008 Global financial crisis QE
uh becomes all the rage and now it seems
like every time we have some sort of
Market downturn people start talking
immediately about QE and QE is like The
New Normal is that how you see this
playing out with sanctions
um there may be some element of that in
the sense that there's a maybe a um
uh
a tendency or or a uh yeah a tendency
for for politicians to reach for
sanctions as a tool because they're
they're perceived uh I mean it sort of
looks good like like they have like you
can go and depress and say oh you know
we're doing something about this bad
situation like look at this big
sanctions package we're unveiling and
you can unveil many of them right so
like you can step them up and step them
down but at the same time you don't have
to actually commit military resources to
addressing uh whatever uh uh issue is is
going on that's that's the root cause of
the sanctions so maybe you know in a
world where military conflict is is very
expensive and where countries are maybe
more at least a little bit more inclined
towards isolationism perhaps at least
there are political movements towards
towards that regard uh these these
sanctions do seem to be kind of like a
very appealing
um alternative and uh so yeah I mean I
I don't necessarily know that I would
call it like a new paradigm but I think
it is maybe sort of a continuation of a
of a trend
um
got it and and what's fascinating about
Russia on just the sanctions part um I
actually tweeted this a couple of days
ago is I saw a graphic that showed the
Imports of all goods between February
and August of 2021 so kind of February
being at a time when Russia invented
Ukraine and the fact that EU trade with
Russia on a whole increased in 2022 uh
despite the sanctions so I'm sorry
February to August of 2022. now the
Nuance there is that commodity prices
were highly volatile and so in dollar or
Euro Euro terms there's actually been an
increase from 21 to 22 with EU country
um going ahead and exporting into Russia
or Russian Imports
um and so what that told me was like
forget for a second uh the nuances of
importing and exporting and dollar
changes of the commodity prices and all
that it's just that sanctions on imports
and exports are very very hard to have
the intended consequences because the
economy is like this big complex machine
but in contrast if your Gold's in my
custody and I say you don't get it back
I am very direct in the in the kind of
uh impact that I want to have you don't
get the gold right so that sanction
almost feels like it's easier to
actually have uh control over and
Implement than maybe playing games with
the nuances of imports and exports and
dollar values and various commodities
yeah I think I think that's right um I
think there I think whenever there's
when when a country tries to Country a
tries to prevent Century B from let's
say importing good X uh if country B
really wants it they can look around the
world and find other people are willing
to sell it from and maybe they have to
pay a higher price for it but uh yeah I
mean as long as there's an economic
incentive there uh you know it seems
that uh that that they probably will
find some whether the will there's a way
um you know and also you know maybe a
good example as to countries like turkey
where they're kind of
uh turning maybe a bit of a blind eye to
enforcing these sanctions and so there's
a lot of business getting set up there
where they're they're essentially acting
as middlemen uh between
um
uh firms like let's say in Europe who
can't who don't want to export directly
to Russia but uh they can export turkey
and then the Turks will you know just
move stuff onward
um so yeah yeah
that makes sense and so in the paper
that you wrote again the title of it was
uh hedging sanctions risk cryptocurrency
and Central Bank Reserves
um you had this data point uh early on
where you say that from 2016 to 2021
countries facing a higher risk of U.S
sanctions increase the gold share of
their reserves more than countries
facing a lower risk of U.S sanctions and
really I think what you're trying to get
at there is countries are not dumb they
know who's at higher risk and lower risk
and therefore they were almost pre- uh
um or kind of in anticipation trying to
become more resilient with the Central
Bank Reserves is that correct
that's that's the argument I make yeah
no I I can't necessarily rule out that
uh countries facing a higher risk of
sanctions which by the way I proxy for
that based on where they're getting
their military imports from uh because I
can't like confuse exactly what a
country's risk of sanctions is I don't
think there's really a way to do that
um but I can't like try to find some
other variable that's that's probably
correlated with it and uh yeah and I
can't necessarily uh rule out that there
the the countries are getting more their
military imports from Russia and China
and therefore at a higher risk of U.S
sanctions that they're increasing their
gold reserves uh because maybe just
because of political considerations like
they find it distasteful the whole U.S
treasury so it's not necessarily that
they're explicitly considering the risk
of sanctions it might be that they're
just making a political decision sort of
a political statement
um so I can't I can't necessarily rule
that out but certainly uh yeah the
evidence is is consistent with uh the
notion that central banks are at least
starting to think about this uh
interesting data point also is that um
uh last uh the last couple quarters of
of uh 2022 there are some big gold
purchases by by central banks uh I think
including China's so
um yeah it's it's happening
the paper in the way that I read it I
think came to kind of three conclusions
um and uh you basically make the
argument on the first point that if
sanctions risk uh exist or is increasing
that would diminish the appeal of U.S
treasuries so I think that historically
central banks have held U.S treasuries
your kind of first conclusion or first
point is really the fact that like they
may get rid of those because of that
sanction risk explain a little bit more
if a country is holding a large portion
of their Central Bank Reserves in U.S
treasuries what the potential damage
could be if they come under the scrutiny
and potential sanctions of the United
States
yeah well I mean they lose act so if
they happen to be sanctioned then they
lose access to that that portion of
their Reserve they can't touch that
money you know sort of like uh it's
almost as if it's been destroyed I mean
because because really the value of
money is in is in the ability to
exchange it for something so if I if you
have an account that has uh 50 billion
dollars in it but you can't you can't
touch it you can't withdraw it you can't
deposit it into it you can't do anything
but it's kind of useful to you it's
almost as if you didn't even have that
money
um so uh yeah I mean so it's it's it's
quite uh quite pernicious and and yeah
so the the conclusion is is that um this
this risk even at relatively low levels
uh has potentially substantial effects
on on the uh portfolio uh allocation
decision of a central bank is so really
what it does is it it kind of takes uh
treasuries which are traditionally
thought of as being a sort of Safe Haven
risk free it turns them into a risky
asset so it doesn't mean you wouldn't
necessarily buy any of them and there
are many other reasons why you might
like them too I mean they're very liquid
uh there are swap lines for example you
can set up with with the Federal Reserve
uh so so there are there are nice things
you can do with these things for for a
central bank but but
um yeah I mean with this risk of
sanctions they sort of turn into they
turn from a risk-free asset to a risky
asset and it's it's uh so it's yeah I
mean it changes it changes the nature of
treasuries
the second conclusion that you come to
is that a increased risk of sanctions
would Propel broader diversification in
Central Bank Reserves so one is like
okay the U.S treasuries themselves may
become less attractive but also central
banks may think about forget anyone
asset we just need broad diversification
to kind of increase the resiliency
explain that a little bit more
yeah that's right well so as long as as
long as uh the the risk of sanctions is
sort of imperfectly correlated which is
to say that
um you know in the case of Russia the
U.S is pretty good about going all
around the world and getting you know
large number of countries to freeze the
reserves and not just NATO by the way
but also Japan and Australia uh New
Zealand and a number of other I think
even South Korea
um so so
you know in the case of Russia it was I
guess almost perfectly correlated but
but as long as it's not it's not
perfectly correlated that there's a
chance that some countries might
sanction you and some may not then
there's an incentive to to Really
diversify so that uh in the event you
get hit with sanctions by some countries
you might still have a portion of your
reserves accessible uh in other
countries that didn't sanction you
and then the last thing that you
conclude is that that increase in
sanctions risk could bolster the
long-run fundamental value of both
cryptocurrency and gold and so we
already talked about gold as something
that central banks are adding talk a
little bit about cryptocurrency as a
whole and then you specifically single
out Bitcoin in the paper uh a number of
times and kind of talk about why you
think that could become one of these
like imperfect substitutes
hey guys I hope that you're enjoying
this interview before we continue I want
to quickly remind you I'm hosting a
conference March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center that's right it's a
big venue for a big event on March 4th
I'm bringing together some of the
absolute fan favorite guests from the
podcast and this show and we're going to
debate ideas the event is called lyceum
Miami the lyceum was the public
gymnasium in Athens Greece that ancient
gymnasium was important because it's a
place where people from all walks of
life came together to have a war of
ideas you were able to not only
participate in the debates but also
people could sit and watch some of the
smartest people in the world talk about
important issues that's what we're going
to be doing on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center if you want to
join us go to lyceumiami.com or click on
the link in the description and I'd love
to see you there okay let's get back to
this conversation
yeah so
um the paper really thinks about uh
cryptocurrency and and so let me
actually start with the the second part
of your question which is sort of why
why Bitcoin
um Bitcoin is by far the largest uh
cryptocurrency and Bitcoin in uh ether
combined uh like 70 of uh market value
of all cryptocurrencies so
um you know just looking at at Bitcoin
uh it gives you a pretty good property
for the sort of the whole uh non-stable
coin cryptocurrency market and
non-stable coin is kind of important
here because stable coins don't really
help you if you're worried about
sanctions because
um U.S dollar coin and tether can can be
sanctioned uh and I and because of the
way they hold U.S solid collateral they
can probably be
uh bullied by the U.S government into
implementing uh sanctions if that's
really what the government wanted to go
down that path
uh so really when it comes to to
cryptocurrency it's got to be sort of
the the uh the the Fiat so the Fiat
cryptocurrencies and it's got to be for
a central bank it's got to be
cryptocurrencies that are big you know
where you can conduct potentially a
billion dollar transaction let's say uh
without you know having a massive impact
on the market price
uh Bitcoin of course today is a lot
smaller than it was when I first started
writing this paper I think it was you
know like forty thousand dollars maybe
around around the time that uh the the
sanctions were applied to Russia
um but it's still you know the market
caps were 300 billion something around
there so so it's
um plenty big enough to conduct uh uh
you know not just transactions of
non-non trivial size
um as far as the fundamental value is
concerned I think there are a lot of use
cases for cryptocurrency that involve
just transacting sort of like you
exchange fiat currency for uh crypto
let's say you then send the crypto as a
remittance to to somebody somewhere else
in the world and then that person swaps
the crypto for another type of Tia
currency so that type of transaction is
not really going to contribute to a
fundamental value because it's just
buying and then reselling so the real
question when it comes to fundamental
value is who's going to be holding on to
this stuff and this paper kind of
confused of of cryptocurrency as as
being a form of insurance
um holding on to it gives you insurance
against the possibility of uh you facing
sanctions and having a large portion of
your wealth through potentially
destroyed
um and in that scenario you still have
these these digital assets and also
maybe gold uh and and so that that that
generates the incentives and to hold on
to this stuff uh sort of to protect
yourself
and so that that's the sense in which it
it's insurance
when you think of Bitcoin specifically
being added is your expectation That
central banks would
um buy the asset let's say they're able
to acquire you know a large portion uh
in dollar terms of uh Bitcoin
have you gone deep enough down the
rabbit hole to start thinking about like
Hollywood custody it are they putting it
on like Hardware devices and they're
like holding it in a vault somewhere are
they like creating their own you know
cryptocurrency custody solution like how
do you just think about uh something
that is um I think to the Bitcoin and
crypto crowd very native to them and
they understand but to a nation state or
a central bank it's very different than
custening almost any other type of asset
yeah that's right um and certainly like
the FTX uh case illustrates that uh you
know just another example of how it's
important to choose your custodian
wisely
um
I think that a central bank would almost
certainly want the self-custody it's
it's Bitcoin they might rely on
exchanges to make the initial purchases
but uh I don't see any reason why they
would want to take the risk of of uh you
know having an exchange blow up and lose
access to a large amount of of
cryptocurrency uh so yeah I think they
would have some kind of self-susting
solution now what you know exactly what
that looks like I I I haven't sort of
delved into the the details of that
um but yeah I I think they would want to
keep it off the balance sheet of some
other uh you know sort of corporate
entity that
uh
potentially uh maybe not not as not that
stable
um yeah I mean this question of uh of
exchanges sort of another interesting
one more broadly and it's definitely
something that the crypto Community has
got to figure out
um yeah
and and what I think becomes kind of
fascinating to me is also in some way
you are mitigating one risk which is U.S
treasuries or sanctions risk at the same
time uh we know that Bitcoin is a bearer
asset and you are increasing the like
Honeypot or the target of malicious
actors around the world now all of a
sudden you're almost increasing the
financial reward for a uh adversarial uh
nation state or adversarial group to
hack your central bank and be able to
somehow get custody of the asset and
again how you custody May determine
whether that's a real risk or not or
whatever but in some ways it almost
feels like you're mitigating one risk
but you may be increasing another is
that true or do you think that nation
states would figure out a way to kind of
mitigate both
yeah no actually I think that's
absolutely true uh and so the paper
doesn't think of cryptocurrency as being
a sort of a free lunch at all I mean it
is it is very much uh optimizing by
trying to sort of balance your exposure
to uh different different risks now the
risk you just pointed out about uh sort
of custody risk and uh sort of the
implications of self-custody as far as
uh cyber security
um there's also of course the risk if
you're self-gusting that you lose access
to your wallet uh you know you're kind
of of a creek
so uh yeah yeah so those are absolutely
things they would have to think about
very very carefully
um uh the other thing I would say though
so this paper thinks more about uh
actually more about sort of the price
volatility and SO trading that off
versus the risk of of sanctions
um uh that's another that's another area
where you're sort of optimizing these
risks where you're if you're adding
Bitcoin to your reserves you're adding
an asset that's much more volatile than
than uh the exchange rates of Fiat
currencies but on the other hand it does
also have this type of insurance value
so
um
that's that's kind of the trade-off that
the papers thinking about
yeah and one of the other pieces of this
uh that it gets into is I'll call it
like the game theory so if all of a
sudden a major uh country in the world
decided to go ahead and add Bitcoin to
it Central Bank Reserves and openly
stated right so it was a known fact to
the world
does that then kind of kick off hey
everyone's got to go buy it because you
almost need a good defense
um
and naturally a finite asset is going to
go up in price if there's an increase in
demand like how do you kind of think
just about like maybe the repercussions
of a major Central Bank somewhere in the
world saying we are buying this and
putting in our Central Bank Reserves
yeah it is an interesting question
um
so certainly El Salvador is is the sort
of the I think the one of well really
one of two countries that hold Bitcoin
the other being Ukraine I think they
basically hold it because they've gotten
donations not because they actually went
out and and actively bought it but but
Al Salvador certainly sort of went out
and said yeah we're buying Bitcoin uh
here's what we're doing I think their
wallet they made their wallets uh
publicly known or at least some of them
um and uh and you know of course they
got a lot of criticism people saying
this is this is crazy like why are you
doing this
um you know you're just basically
lighting money on fire which of course
and I think the their the average price
they paid for their Bitcoin is somewhere
in like the 30 to 40K range so so they
have lost a fair bit on on on on their
Bitcoin in terms of the market price
um
but uh uh yeah I mean there is this
interesting question of if you're going
to buy Bitcoin do you reveal it in in
the paper
I also talked about like uh does maybe
not revealing it also makes you a little
bit more resilient to sanctions because
the U.S treasury can certainly add
cryptocurrency while it's onto a
sanctions list and that that has the
force of law behind it so as a U.S
person you cannot lawfully transact with
a cryptocurrency wallet that's on the
U.S expansion list and if you do the
penalties are quite severe uh like civil
and criminal penalties
uh so but but of course the U.S treasury
can't sanction something it doesn't know
about so so uh if if Central Bank uh you
know x uh is is buying Bitcoin is
thinking about is this type of insurance
and it seems that it might actually be
better for them to just kind of do it
quietly uh a couple other points about
that too are that um
yeah as you pointed out if if uh if a
number of the number of larger central
banks started announcing they were they
were buying Bitcoin uh yeah you think
you probably would lose the price of it
so they probably wouldn't like that
because they routed by Bitcoin when it's
cheap then after they've moved the price
up by announcing it they're doing it
right so like there's always there's
never an incentive to tell the financial
markets and Advance what your plan is
right so you always want to sell them
after the fact uh so you don't you don't
move the prices uh uh before you trade
um uh yeah yeah
and when you start to really almost
critically think about Ace nation state
somewhere in the world doing this
is it fair to say it'd be the nation
states with the highest sanctions risk
like El Salvador I don't think has very
high sanctions risk at least when they
started they were doing it more from
like a financial incentive standpoint a
uh prosperity for their future citizens
um or at least that was what the talk
track was
um what you're talking about here is
like people who almost are doing it at a
necessity is that really the thought
process of like the major countries are
only going to do that of necessity
they're not going to go and uh
essentially speculate on the on the
future price of a commodity
yeah so I think I think you're right
that that uh at least I I never saw
anything about El Salvador claiming that
they were thinking about Bitcoin as a
form of insurance and I think that
speculation is a very bad reason for
anybody to purchase anything and that
includes uh just ordinary people and and
central banks I mean it's it's
supremely difficult to forecast uh the
prices of financial assets so
um especially when you have something as
volatile as Bitcoin I think you're going
to buy it the reason really ought to be
that you're buying it because it fills
some particular need in your portfolio
there's something about the
characteristics of it that are well
aligned with the risks that you
personally face as an investor rather
than that you just think the price is
going to go up because maybe it will but
maybe it won't right so
um uh yeah so so yeah so and and along
those veins yes the paper would suggest
that certainly would suggested that the
country is facing the highest risk of
sanctions have the strongest incentive
to to think about uh acquiring some
Bitcoin now whether they want to or not
is also going to be a function of
whether for example they feel like they
can get enough gold I mean gold in the
paper really emerges as
the uh sort of the premiere or the
primary or first choice for for
protecting yourself against this type of
risk because it's just so much more
stable than than cryptocurrency you know
it has a multi-thousand year history
behind it
um so uh but but if if you've got a
central bank that for example doesn't
have the capability of storing physical
gold like it doesn't have any faults for
doing that
um and they think they're kind of
worried about this type of risk then uh
potentially they might want to acquire a
decent amount of cryptocurrency yeah
do you think that there are any
countries around the world who likely
have already done this and just not
revealed it or is it too hard to kind of
guess in terms of where we are from like
a adoption standpoint of nation states
and central banks
yeah I mean of course I I I wouldn't
know for sure but I it wouldn't surprise
me at all if there are some that are
doing it or not reviewing it uh there is
actually some interesting evidence that
countries tend to under report their
gold Holdings uh because they don't like
having a report that they take they've
taken a loss on on their gold uh when
the price drops and uh and so if there's
an incentive to do that for gold then
certainly to be a much stronger
incentive to underreport cryptocurrency
Holdings not only because they get
exposed to criticism from kind of the
more traditional Finance Community but
also because uh you know they have this
it's so much more volatile than than
gold uh so they have this this incentive
to to not reveal it for a number of
reasons first they don't want to move
the market price second uh there's this
volatility that they don't necessarily
want to have to explain away uh and um
and then third that not disposing a
really kind of maybe boosters the the
insurance value of of having these these
uh decentralized tokens so
um yeah I mean I think there's there's
the incentives are there not to to
reveal it and I also I wouldn't be
surprised also if there are some
countries where they've acquired some uh
Bitcoin let's say but they're doing it
to their Sovereign wealth fund rather
than to their Central Bank Reserves so
there may also maybe just some
accounting as to you know which entity
they used to buy it or how they kind of
keep it off the books so to speak
um but no I mean I wouldn't it wouldn't
surprise me at all
as you see these central banks
um whether they are actually announcing
it or not whether they're buying it or
not one of the things I've been most
surprised by is it seems like Central
Bank digital currencies has gotten a ton
of uh momentum support uh uh a lot of
Mind share a lot of papers you just see
like kind of the wheels are churning
right Bitcoin seems to be the uh maybe
the enemy and maybe that's like an
exaggeration but like it's very much
like no not Bitcoin yes this Central
Bank digital currency is interesting
how much of that is uh they may not be
educated or taking the time to
understand Bitcoin versus the central
banks are very educated and they kind of
understand exactly what the pros and
cons of a central bank digital currency
a Bitcoin and everything in between is
and they're kind of taking more of a uh
aspirational position in terms of what
they hoped happens versus uh you know
kind of uh almost being ignorant to
something like Bitcoin
yeah I mean I don't think any Central
Bank sort of wants to willingly just
abandon kind of its job uh as far as
sort of facilitating
we are currently transaction is sort of
guarding and safeguarding that that
system uh and then just sort of throw up
their hands and say okay we give up and
you know we think everybody should just
start using crypto so
you know it almost is almost like a
sense of self-preservation here that
it's that uh you know that they they
don't necessarily want uh uh to to kind
of just close up shop but
um I mean you know the the price
volatility of Bitcoin is really quite
quite problematic I mean you just can't
run an economy on an app that swings up
and down you know five ten percent in a
single day it's just too too much
um
and and uh and uh uh as far as the
digital currencies too I mean I think I
think a lot of that is also more
sort of technological or as far as um
just thinking about kind of improving
the plumbing of the financial system
like how are transactions settled and
cleared uh things like that um I mean
those those are very important questions
and they do have implications for uh
Financial stability and um so they're
important to to understand
um but that's that's also why you know
there's I think there's a lot of ink
getting spilled on on that
you mentioned earlier before we got
started that uh you had seen some of the
past interviews I've done on bitcoin and
uh some stuff we agree on some stuff we
don't agree on
um rather than aboard the audience and
probably you and myself on the things we
agree on what are some of the things
that uh we did you you believe we
disagree on it maybe we could kind of
talk through those uh and I'd love to
learn you know from from your side and
maybe uh you could uh stumble into one
or two things uh if I put my foot in my
mouth
okay sure yeah yeah and you know of
course just because we disagree on it
doesn't mean uh I'm right and you're
wrong right I mean we just have a
difference of opinion
um
uh I guess uh maybe one of them we can
talk about is is that there's kind of
this I think there's this this tension
between the notion that uh Bitcoin is it
sort of represents uh free speech and
that it's used for sort of legitimate
purposes
uh you know related to like furthering
democracy and people's own you know Free
Will and so forth there's like a natural
tension between that and then this
notion that it's resistant against
sanctions because if if the government
uh doesn't want you doing something
they're going to declare it illegal and
if you're going to do it anyway with
Bitcoin then you're breaking the law so
you know I think that
a part of even if Bitcoin is not used to
a great extent today uh for the purpose
of facilitating illegal activity I mean
like for example the um
there's an analytics firm called chain
analysis that looks at blockchain
transactions and and they say that a
pretty small portion of uh of Bitcoin is
is used in illegal activity now maybe
maybe they're just not counting it
correctly but but I think that like if
you're going to argue that the
cryptocurrencies are not used for
illegal things
uh
maybe that's not true maybe that's true
today but you have to at least
acknowledge it like an important aspect
of them is that they could be like they
could be used for that in the future and
and that actually is like an important
part of what what gives them value like
like I was describing them as insurance
um now you can certainly argue whether
uh the government should be making
certain things illegal or not but the
fact that you have the option of
bypassing that uh you know there is kind
of that that tension there
um yeah I I think it's a very fair
question and if we separate out for a
second uh um the illegal activities uh
from the legal activities I think when
people say that uh Bitcoin is kind of
free speech codified right uh the first
thing is
um in the United States you have the
right to free speech now there are
limitations around certain things you
know yelling fire in a movie theater all
of those types of things but generally
if you're trying to uh do good things or
legal things uh you are allowed to say
what you want and uh actually the true
test of free speech is almost to protect
the speech of the people you disagree
with right but they're not uh inciting
violence or any of this stuff and so um
what Bitcoin does uh which is unique for
uh money is that it provides this
censorship resistance right now what is
censorship meant to be what is it not
meant to be when is it appropriate when
is it not that's definitely debated I
think that gets more into like the legal
and illegal transactions but just from a
technical basis the fact that I can send
Bitcoin to you and I don't need to ask
permission from anyone else is a
technical Innovation when it comes to uh
being able to use economic value
something with a market price and use
for medium of exchange so I think it's
like pretty well accepted uh let's say
on the technical basis of just like
there is this censorship resistance you
know you mentioned uh the insurance is a
form of that censorship resistance uh
for the central banks whatever now when
it gets into legal and illegal I
actually think most people look at the
illegal transactions and I always joke
that like yes there are anarchists yes
there are like hardcore Libertarians
that believe like there should be no
rules or laws or whatever
um but like generally most people in a
society agree on the illegal things that
they should be illegal right if you are
financing terrorism or whatever it is uh
for the most part I think the majority
of these societies say hey we should not
uh allow that to happen and it's good
that we prevent bad things from
happening to to our citizens well wait
let me uh let me uh let me interrupt you
just for a second and what about for
example uh protesting Canada's
vaccination policy I mean uh the the
government declared that illegal and
they they froze their banking out so if
they were if any of those protesters
were transacting in Bitcoin they were
breaking the law right so so the
question is
um but just because the government makes
it a law doesn't mean that it is a
ethical law right now and the example I
always the example I always use is like
um if they had done that in the United
States
right they would have violated the
Constitution
now I'm not an expert on Canadian
politics nor what their legal documents
are so like maybe it's legal maybe it's
not I'm not sure but in the United
States if uh the government had said hey
we are basically going to remove you
we're going to eject you from the
financial system because you are not
complying with a whether it's
vaccination or any other law uh I think
that there would have been a line out of
the courtroom door of lawyers saying hey
you know you're violating people's uh
various constitutional rights
and so like it's a very weird thing
because in some ways uh without
censorship resistant money the default
is the government's right the
individuals are wrong
when there is censorship resistant money
in my opinion and again this is just me
individually it kind of balances out the
powers and now all of a sudden it is the
individual is right and the government
the burden of proof goes to the
government that they broke the law or
whatever now what I think we have seen
which you know kind of gets at this a
little bit is we've actually seen a lot
of law enforcement organizations a lot
of politicians and governments all say
like look bad people have done bad
things on the blockchain 100 right like
we know that's happened and they've been
able to go track those people down and
kind of bring them to justice whatever
that ended up being and so it it almost
gets at this question of like who should
be believed by default or like who
should be given the the uh the default
right to continue until something else
changes and it's like is it the
government or is it the individual and
ultimately as you know I'm assuming uh
you would guess is like it just comes
down to like political perspectives
which is like a weird thing because
Bitcoin is technology it's software it's
like the least political thing from a
technical architecture but it gets
almost
um uh kind of brought into these
political discussions because to your
point it allows for people to do things
that they previously couldn't have done
which opens up this whole can of worms
right
yeah yeah that's right I mean yeah so I
I think um
I think I think basically you know you
just have to acknowledge that it
it can be used for things the government
doesn't want people to use and and and
that's that's that's part of the the the
value of it but but yeah I mean whether
that's
whether that's good or bad I guess also
depends on you know how
how good you think governments are at
being the Arbiter of of right and wrong
yeah right sort of philosophical
questions
um but uh yeah so okay maybe a couple
other things too um so I think you've
also mentioned before that like
uh bank failures and maybe like the
potential for confiscation like what
happened in Cyprus is a good reason for
people to hold Bitcoin is do I have that
right
I think it's less about like hey that's
a reason everyone should go out and you
know buy Bitcoin I think it's more so
um the idea of self-custody similar to
the central banks right uh the more
custody you have the more sovereignty
you have of the assets it pers it
prevents against those edge cases and
they're very much education is in the
developed world in the less developed
world they're probably more common uh
and there's also not things like FDIC
Insurance Etc but it's definitely one of
the reasons why sovereignty uh becomes
important in my opinion
yeah okay I guess I think I think maybe
we would we would then mostly agree on
that that uh you know in the in the
developed world it's not so much of a
concern uh there are by the way ways to
to to increase your your FDIC Insurance
like quite a bit I mean you can open up
multiple bank accounts uh you can
actually add beneficiaries to them so if
you had beneficiaries to a bank account
it actually Stacks up the FDIC Insurance
uh to to up to uh 1.25 million
um so so yeah I mean I I think that
the the number of people who would
actually need to to start thinking about
buying Bitcoin because they like run out
of banks to open you know to deposit
their money out I think is it's got to
be vanishingly uh vanishingly small
um so another thing I maybe we'll we'll
disagree a bit more on this is
I'm actually not necessarily convinced
that cryptocurrency is currency
um I mean it's obviously the term that
people call it and so I I use it but
I don't think that Bitcoin is it is not
a currency it's not a unit of account
it's not a medium of exchange like I I
can't go to the grocery store and hand
the Bitcoin for for groceries uh I can't
go to the movie theater and and pay
Bitcoin to to go watch watch a movie uh
Amazon will not accept my Bitcoins for
selling me
you know whatever it is that Amazon
sells is everything
um so so it it it's more of a niche
thing and now I I do however think it is
a store of value
um but but it it's not
it's not yet at the level of a currency
um now it like gold for example isn't
isn't a currency either
um you know if I none of those places I
just told you about will will accept my
uh gold bullion right so if I if I bring
a bar of gold to the grocery store or
whatever they're not going to accept
that
um
but
yeah I mean so I think I think that um
thinking of of these things as as I mean
so they're just not yet currencies uh
that doesn't mean that they won't ever
be
um and maybe part of the the Again part
of the sort of the insurance you're
you're getting when you buy Bitcoin is
that you're kind of protecting yourself
against the scenario where somehow the
US dollar becomes
but worthless or something like like
there's some major uh either policy
screw-ups or like a nuclear war or
something and in that scenario maybe
cryptocurrencies actually started
becoming like a unit of account because
like Society is sort of broken down or
something
um
uh but but I don't know just today I
just I don't see it
so I I have two things that kind of jump
to mind uh the first is I'm gonna throw
out a like definition of a currency and
you tell me if this is aligned with
yours uh I heard you say a couple things
I'm assuming it's like store value
medium of exchange and unit of account
would be the three yeah yeah
okay so I would agree with that and I
think that's like a good um framework
and my guess is that most people who are
uh quote-unquote currency experts would
would say hey yes that checks the boxes
of that now where uh I may question some
of those currency experts is a lot of
times when I hear people talk about is
something a currency or is it not
obviously given what I do on a
day-to-day basis a lot of time to talk
about Bitcoin um but there are other
assets that you you know you mentioned
gold and others that can kind of come
under this scrutiny
um one of the things that I've sort of
think about more and I certainly don't
have a fully formed opinion so I'll kind
of throw it out there as a uh maybe a
prompt and you can respond to it is that
actually some assets or currencies in
one situation but not currencies in
another and what it made me think about
is like environment matters when
evaluating if something's a currency or
not and where this came from was I used
to use the example of cigarettes inside
of a prison and so like again kind of
extreme example right but but it
highlights the point of like they're
used as a store value they're used as a
medium of exchange and to some degree
they're used as like a unit of account
right it's more of like a barter type
system and and they're used now I don't
think anyone who uh wants to be taken
seriously in the financial world or in
the academic world would go and say you
know cigarettes are a currency all
around the world and if you've got
cigarettes you're good to go
um but in that you know kind of more
insular environment they do act as a
currency and so if you take that and
kind of extrapolate it out to bitcoin
it's Unique in that uh I think most
people who hold Bitcoin
um and even people who don't but but uh
kind of evaluate it they would agree yes
Bitcoin serves as a store value now
whether it's a good one or a bad one
that's debated you know free market kind
of determines price and it changes or
and fluctuates but store value I think
most people are like okay you know I can
see that when it comes to the medium of
exchange and the unit of account that's
where I think you know you're
highlighting hey look this is not
widespread this is not Global and so if
you use that like well what environment
are you talking about in a physical
environment if you go to you know
Bitcoin Beach there's a lot of people
who are using it for transactions things
are priced in Bitcoin but I don't know
maybe there's a couple hundred maybe you
know single digit thousands of people in
that one insular economy that are using
it again does that make it a currency on
a global scale does that mean that it's
just within that insular economy is that
the first data point on a you know
upwards trajectory of adoption globally
all Up For Debate but but at least in
that insular thing it's being used as a
currency but I would agree with you on a
global basis it is not unit of account
there has not been you know this hyper
bitcoinization idea uh all of those
types of things and so like you know the
The Prompt that I would almost kind of
want to hear your thoughts on is like
how do folks who look at these
currencies think about you know Global
uh evaluation versus more of like these
insular economies and can some thing
almost serve you know to some people as
a currency and to other people it's
actually not a currency like they
actively are on the other side of that
debate how does that work
hey guys I hope that you're enjoying
this conversation as you probably
realize we don't run any ads on this
show that's right all the other podcasts
all the other YouTube shows that you
watch they have advertisers we don't
have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pomp
letter it's a daily letter that I write
to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis all right let's get back
into this conversation yeah that
actually is an interesting question
because uh for example
um the things that I just described uh
like going to the grocery store or the
movie theater or whatever
if I'm doing that in the United States
and I brought a Euro banknote uh to the
grocery store the movie theater they
wouldn't take that either so in in that
setting it it's not the euro banknote is
not acting as a currency even though of
course uh we we would uh generally
recognize the euro to be a currency and
certainly anywhere in the European Union
and many countries besides that uh it
would be accepted uh for for those kinds
of transactions so
um yeah I mean I guess so that there is
there is a inherently a sort of um like
a time place and manner type uh uh
uh notion to to the concept of a
currency but but still
um I I think that it's got to be more a
lot more widespread than than Bitcoin
currently is
um yeah yeah and I think to your point
it's like um you know one of the things
I've always said is like if Bitcoin
becomes a store of value it does not
necessarily
um achieve what is written in the white
paper right electronic peer-to-peer cash
like it's very much intended to be both
a store value medium exchange and then
eventually that would lead to the unit
of account but at the same time if it
became the global store of value that
was used by billions of people like that
would be a pretty big success right so
so just that alone would kind of uh um I
think a lot of people would point to and
say hey Bitcoin worked for that specific
use case now obviously people in the
Bitcoin Community believe that it is
going to become the medium of exchange
and that unit of account and so the
other thing I always laugh about it was
kind of like um with the inflation talk
in the United States they're like you
know it's transitory it's not transitory
I used to always say like well what what
makes like where's the line right if
it's only here for six months is that
transitory but but if it's here for
seven then it wasn't transitory you know
it's kind of like this like very
arbitrary loose definition that's used
and so same thing with like medium of
exchange right as I almost think about
like if a hundred million people used it
for everyday transactions is that enough
well there's like you know seven and a
half eight billion people whatever it is
in the world like uh you know we're not
even really at like you know ten percent
does it have to be a billion like
where's the line and a friend of mine uh
said to me he goes nah it's more of like
a you know it when you see it thing and
I think that's kind of how people feel a
little bit is like okay I I feel like
it's a store of value for enough people
we're like I'll buy that I don't know
enough people who use it on a day-to-day
basis so like I kind of don't believe
that story yet and then I when I go to
the store I don't see it priced in
Bitcoin so like I don't believe the unit
of account
um but I don't know maybe like there are
definitions of this stuff that like you
know the the Bitcoin Community just
hasn't talked about yet it's like a very
fascinating thing that
um in some way the Bitcoin community and
myself personally like we've gotten a
crash course in economics the banking
system like currencies like all this
stuff and I always wonder like how much
of it is we're learning versus like
we're trying to recreate the wheel and
like we maybe should just like learn
from history a little bit at the same
time
yeah yeah no I mean I I certainly don't
know off the top of my head of any kind
of like specific definition as far as
let's say how many people have to use
something in order for it to be uh
considered a currency
um
you know I I guess I just go back to the
Beauties in the eye of the beholder
right yes so
um on the other hand the one thing I
will I do want to respond to uh in in um
that you just had mentioned like talking
about millions of people using it
um you know my my paper actually kind of
gets really is thinking more like you
know like a hundred institutions or
something right like or maybe no more
than 150 or something
um and so like
in terms of of
Bitcoin becoming used as a unit of
account or medium of exchange you know I
I think actually those are quite quite
separable from from being a store of
value and and what and and the store
value doesn't necessarily imply the
other two at all I mean again go back to
the sample of gold I mean people have
been
using gold to store value for uh
thousands of years but
um it's been quite some time since it's
been thought of as as a unit of account
or a medium of exchange so yeah
yeah look I I completely agree and again
it goes back to this idea of like
Bitcoin layer one right kind of the the
uh core blockchain
um is very much built for security right
I don't think anyone would look at a
blockchain that has 10 minute settlement
times uh and they would say like
obviously that is optimized for Global
adoption to be used as a medium of
exchange and so that's where the Bitcoin
Community is trying to build the scaling
Technologies of lightning and you know
kind of all of that stuff
um and you know I would argue that like
so far it looks pretty good but I do
think that there's a lot of things that
that
um you know still need to be built out
and also I think the critique being okay
I theoretically understand what you're
trying to do but like prove it show me
the adoption it's very similar to like a
venture capitalist showing up to a
company and saying like this is a
beautiful deck but like show me the
users show me the retention show me the
growth right and I think that's kind of
like the market will ultimately be the
referee a little bit in terms of uh how
far along the like Bitcoin Vision do we
get
um and obviously that's where markets
get made because the Bitcoin Community
uh is very very you know optimistic and
and enthusiastic and then I think that
critics are saying you know that I don't
see a path from where we are today to to
that vision and we'll kind of see what
happens the the only thing I hope for is
you know it happens in our lifetimes
right like I want an answer before I die
it's like the way that I've now come to
the conclusion this isn't a 12-month
exercise it's probably a couple decades
and it's like let's see where it kind of
goes
um but I don't know what what is your
kind of maybe we'll we'll end here in
terms of like what what are your
thoughts in terms of uh the biggest
Milestones like like I take you as
somebody who maybe is
um cautiously optimistic is maybe where
I would kind of characterize your view
of uh Bitcoin optimistic being like you
see some use cases like the insurance
for central banks but like cautious in
terms of the critiques of it's not a
medium of exchange it's not a currency
things like that is that like maybe a
fair kind of bucket to put you in if you
would allow me to put you in a bucket
um yeah and I would also just say I
don't think it's for everyone so so like
you know if you're living in a developed
country and you have no real reason to
believe that you know your assets are
likely to be confiscated or that um
you know you're
in a situation where where uh
you know the government's gonna pursue
like civil asset forfeiture or something
against you then then I think the
argument for you to to buy Bitcoin
certainly by a lot of Bitcoin is is
very tenuous
um like like there's just you know you
but because again like you're not
getting an insurance benefit out of it
so if all you're doing is just
speculating
that's that's probably not a uh again
you want to be playing
um for the vast majority of people so so
yeah so I think I think there are
absolutely some use cases uh for for
some people but it's not it's not for
everybody
um what would change my mind a lot on
that uh would be if it became a lot less
volatile so if if the if the price
volatility really came down
um then you know then it might actually
because then it's almost like you have
your case you get this insurance value
and it also the stable you know thing
where you don't have to uh worry about
it dropping you know 75 in one year like
it did last year
um
so
yeah I did I so I think I think uh
I think you you you had me uh mostly uh
pegged correctly
so the the volatility question is
actually uh pretty interesting I want to
throw an idea out there and um I'm gonna
allow myself to uh say Department of
Economics Harvard you probably are are
much better versed in this than I am but
um from kind of a Layman's view of this
one one of the questions around
volatility that I struggle with uh one
articulating but also two even just
understanding is that like it's very
clear bitcoin's volatility because we
use the dollar exchange price right so I
will take one Bitcoin today someone will
buy for seventeen thousand three hundred
dollars uh two weeks ago they would buy
for 15 and a year ago they were buying
it for sixty nine thousand dollars or
you know whatever the numbers were so
obviously that Exchange price is super
volatile when I think of dollars no one
really thinks of them as volatile
because I get paid in dollars I save in
dollars I buy all my goods and services
in dollars I pay my taxes and dollars
like everything around me is denominated
in dollars but if I was to pull back and
look at like the purchasing power
obviously with you know the official
inflation numbers compounding it over
seven percent for multiple years you're
like okay I don't know you know 12 to 20
inflation over let's call it the the
pandemic era or whatever depending on
kind of what numbers you want to believe
but we don't think of dollars as
volatile right because it's like one
dollar buys you one dollar worth of
goods it's just the amount of goods has
changed how do you think about or maybe
if you're even me like talking about
Bitcoin volatility compared to like
dollar volatility or do you think that
they're just apples and oranges and it's
like unfair to try to compare them
well I mean that's that's kind of uh the
concept of a real exchange rate right
sort of like how much
um how much does a currency uh move
around in terms of the the amount of
consumption that that it buys you uh in
terms of a dollar yeah that's that's a
wrote it's um uh because of of uh uh
inflation uh but also uh just also in
terms of uh it's moved around uh
relative to to other currencies so yeah
I mean you always have to when you're
measuring an exchange rate you're either
measuring it against something right you
have to measure it again
the dollars against euros dollars
against Yen you know Bitcoin against
dollars whatever
um
uh but I think no matter how you measure
it you know Bitcoin again X you know
whatever X is I think uh you're gonna
find that that's very volatile in terms
of whether you measure it in terms of
just the X itself or you then take the
step further and measure in terms of
units of consumption
um
so
yeah yeah the the one other thing I
would say about this that
um again it kind of adds a complexity to
to the analysis and sometimes I wonder
if we're just like intellectually
stimulating ourselves because we're all
bored and have nothing else to discuss
um but if you think of uh the day-to-day
volatility it would be very hard for
anyone to argue that Bitcoin does not go
up and down in value at a much rapid
rate compared to the US dollar right I
think that's pretty clear but if you
were to look over again let's go back to
kind of 2020 to now I'll call it the
pandemic era if you will
um the dollar is down whatever that
number is right whether it's on the
lower end of 10 or maybe on the upper
end of 20 it's down some double digit
percentage
um Bitcoin has gone up and down and up
and down and it's been like you know
just whipped around but it's up 200
percent from where it started 2020 right
so kind of over that three year period
it's up kind of 200 or so and so the way
that I I think about this is like on one
hand uh with dollar denomination assets
and goods and services have gotten more
expensive over that three-year period
but if you had the Bitcoin denomination
things have gotten cut in half in terms
of like your purchasing power and your
ability to buy goods and services
I don't think many people are picking
their day-to-day currency based on a
three or you know even five or ten year
time Horizon I think it's more that
store of value as you mentioned earlier
but how would you kind of think through
that or and maybe even doesn't work on
it of like
in the short term something super
volatile compared to a more stable asset
like the dollar but in the long term it
seems to actually have a better store of
value and kind of almost have this
Tailwind for people who hold it that
then want to consume using it
um yeah so I think that uh
I think you have to be careful when when
you're when you're conducting an
analysis like this because it's going to
matter greatly where you choose the
starting point and the ending point
right so uh I mean as you pointed out
you know one way of looking at Bitcoin
is that you're up 200 over the last what
like three years did you say three years
or since 2020 or something no yeah
another way of looking at it is you're
down 75 last year correct yeah so so it
matters a timeline the more the pain I
think of like the shorter the timeline
the more the pain the longer the
timeline the more it looks good for you
know the Bitcoin uh holder if you will
yeah I I but I do I do think that uh
Bitcoin holders have got to expect even
over longer time frames that the returns
are not going to be as high as they have
been
um I mean I think the the early adopters
of big I mean you bought Bitcoin in like
2010 or something like you know clearly
I wish yeah yeah clearly you've done
super super well
um I actually remember taking a course
on cryptography as an undergrad where
people brought up Bitcoin like as an
interesting like academic curiosity
almost I think it was like ten dollars
or something back then so yeah I kind of
wish I had it
I wish I knew you it was in that class
yeah but uh
um
you know in order for like like there's
just there's just no like economic
rationale for why
or let's say 10 then like the next 10
years Bitcoin should return you know
thousands of percent I mean it's just
like I I just struggle to come up with
any kind of plausible
um reason for for why that ought to be
the case I mean if it's
if it's going to act as a store of value
and sort of a real asset then the rate
of return ought to be much closer to the
rate of inflation and
um you know I think that that if you're
gonna buy Bitcoin that that ought to be
uh you're closer to your your
expectation than uh you know the kinds
of fantastic returns that people got
when Bitcoin and you know back then it
was it was a riskier thing I mean people
had no idea whether it was going to work
out I mean it you know it could have had
maybe someone could have successfully
attacked it or found bugs in the in the
protocol right I mean like there are all
kinds of risk so related to the early
adoption of the cryptocurrency that have
I think nowadays been more or less
settled that you know we know that this
thing is fairly secure and and robust
because uh there certainly are enough
people using it today and that have you
know kind of looked at the code and
everything and made sure that that
everything checks out
um but back when when it got started I
mean I don't think that that was
necessarily the case so
yeah the early adopters got some some
risk premium for that and uh but but
there's no there's just no reason why
uh it's Gonna Keep producing these kinds
of tremendous returns so I think yeah
you got to expect inflation maybe
inflation plus one inflation plus two or
something but you know that that's
that's probably the long the long run
for for Bitcoin yeah I I actually agree
with you I I don't think that
um you will continue to see like I call
like video game number returns right I
think at some point those taper off
um and yes everyone loves the stories of
hundreds or thousands of percent you
know tens of thousands of percent
um but but I think you nailed it in that
like you get paid for the risk you take
and now Bitcoin has been drastically
de-risked in a number of different
vectors they're still you know plenty of
people who have certain risks or or
concerns or whatever but but many of the
major risks have been uh at least
mitigated if not completely uh removed
and so you should expect the return to
go down um but the other thing too uh
and again maybe this kind of gets at the
the dollar Bitcoin thing is
I don't know if they necessarily are
competitive on a short to medium uh time
Horizon and so like I think that the
Bitcoin Community does a great job of
like pointing you know a century away
and they're like look what's going to
happen 100 years from now maybe right I
don't I don't think I'll be alive for
that but I do think that in the next you
know I don't know let's just say 10 or
20 years like the US dollar likely will
continue to uh strengthen against other
Fiat currencies and kind of become you
know at least uh hold its position if
not become more dominant against weaker
currencies uh and that will continue to
be used as the day-to-day medium of
exchange but Bitcoin maybe it just
continues to gain steam as a store of
value right and and uh it kind of has
this rise with the dollar and they
coexist for quite a bit
um and that can be separate and distinct
from what happens in the long run
right like to me it's not a uh just
because they're structurally set up some
way you don't necessarily have to
conclude that the end game is what
happens you know even In Our Lifetime
let alone in the next 10 or 20 years
um which is unique because then it kind
of again if you unpack it the dollar is
designed to lose a little bit of value
through inflation every year to Spur the
economic activity and kind of all the
things that uh people understand Bitcoin
is almost engineered in a way that
although it'll have short-term
volatility in the long run to kind of
continue to gain some purchasing power
just because it's a finite asset and as
more people adopt it it should go up in
that purchasing power terms
um but I think as you kind of started
the conversation like we we don't know
for sure right like it is uh these
questions are worth asking because
ultimately the market will kind of
determine it but
um we need to kind of understand what
we're what the risks are and what the
potential Pros are and we go from there
yeah I mean I so I'm not actually not
necessarily sure that he over a 10 or 20
year period the dollar will appreciate
or or depreciate I mean that's also
going to send a great deal on the course
of monetary policy in in the U.S
compared to the to the rest of the world
um and then whether the US dollar
continues to gain traction
as as a you know sort of a medium of
exchange or unit of account in in
international trade
I don't know I mean I I think
you know the countries like uh like
China for example has been very
insistent again and interested in trying
to heal countries away from dealing in
US dollars to dealing in in well
probably the prefer renmbi but it's not
that then at least something else
um so yeah I mean I I think uh I I I I
actually think we're probably headed
more towards the sort of a multi-collar
International Financial system where if
a dollar maybe is a plurality but it's
not going to be like the dominant
majority Force like like it has been
um and I think that Bitcoin may be one
of the smaller things that's part of
that and maybe it uses a store of value
um but but yeah and you know actually so
as far as like the long run in Bitcoin
the last Bitcoin will be mined what in
like 21 36 2140 um something like that I
think yeah yeah so so certainly um you
know be interesting to
to know what will happen uh with with
Bitcoin after that I mean like are the
are the transaction fees going to be
enough to sustain it
um you know to to incentivize minors to
continue and continue mining are people
going to be willing to pay fees that are
that high I mean that's sort of an
interesting question but yeah
unfortunately uh I will be dead by then
so
you you and I both will uh we'll we'll
we'll be on our deathbed wondering I
wonder what's gonna happen and hopefully
uh we we unfortunately will never know
Matthew I really enjoyed talking uh this
is uh this is fantastic and and um I
really appreciate it I think kind of
just your critical thinking around so
many of these topics if anyone wants to
reach out or learn more of the work that
you're doing where can we send them to
find you on the internet
yeah um so I have a I have my contact
information is on a Google site um so if
you just Google my name uh it'll it'll
come up um and there's also a link there
where you can
download my my paper or whatever the
current version of it is so I'm working
on a a revision
um uh and if you want to read it I'm
always interested in hearing from people
of thoughts and and uh feedback on on my
work on my work so yeah
awesome and for those that um want to go
check out the paper again it is uh
titled hedging sanctions risk
cryptocurrency and Central Bank Reserves
uh published back in or the original was
published in November of 2022
um but Matthew thank you so much I I
learned a ton today and I hope that this
was valuable for everyone uh watching
and listening and uh please uh kind of
keep pushing forward because uh there's
a lot of people I think as you realized
once the once you published the paper
who uh who are paying attention to this
space and and found your paper valuable
as well so thank you
yeah thank you very much for having me
on it was a fun conversation